all right let's get right into this
absolutely incredible hearing that took
place yesterday there was a senate
hearing yesterday on
covid dr anthony fauci testified cdc
director rachelle wolinski testified
and there are
there are three or four different
controversies that came from this
including dr fauci being caught on a hot
mic
saying that senator roger marshall is a
[ __ ] which i will prove to you that he
is in in the next segment but the first
big confrontation was between dr fauci
and republican senator rand paul
senator rand paul has been determined
from the start of the pandemic to say
this is no big deal we don't need masks
we don't need vaccines but more
dangerously fauci's a bad actor to the
point that people have actually gone
after fauci fauci now needs full-time
security
so let's get right into this the
beginning is dr fauci being grilled by
rand paul about emails let's just jump
right in do you really think it's
appropriate to use your 420 000 salary
to attack scientists that disagree with
you oh and that's the new thing now also
that they're obsessed with fouchy's
salary which comes up
the email you're referring to was an
email
of dr collins to me if you look at the
email that you responded to and hurried
up and said i can do it i can do it we
got something in wired oh no i think in
usual fashion
senator you are distorting everything
about me did you ever object to dr
collins's characterization of them as
friends did you write back to dr collins
no characterization
scientist and it would be beneath me i
did not do that you responded to him
that you would do it and you immediately
got an article in the wire and you sent
it back to him said hey look i've got
them i nailed them in wired of all
scientists
went on you there you go again you just
do the same thing every year that was
your response and this wasn't this
wasn't the only time so your desire to
take down people incorrect as usual what
is the point of this like we're not
learning about the pandemic here we're
not getting closer to dealing with it
with rand paul's lines of questioning
it's just him trying to get appearances
on fox news which which happens whenever
he does this senator you are incorrect
almost everything well no you deny you
deny but the emails tell the truth of
this no this wasn't the only time your
desire to take down those who disagree
with you didn't stop with harvard oxford
and stanford you conspired with peter
dazak who you communicated with
privately and other members of the
scientific community that wrote opinion
pieces for nature five of them signed a
paper for nature an opinion piece 17
signed a paper that called it conspiracy
theory the idea that the virus could
have originated in the lab do you think
words like conspiracy theory should be
in a scientific paper
senator i never used that word when i
was referring to it you're distorting
virtually everything did you communicate
with the five scientists who wrote the
opinion piece in nature where they were
describing oh this there's no way this
could happen me would i did you talk
with any of those so as you can see he
can barely even get a word in
eventually
dr fauci unleashes and says
i am getting threats from people getting
caught with guns
listen to what dr fauci reveals here you
know i guess you could say well that's
the way it goes i can take the hit
well it it makes a difference because as
some of you may know
just about three or four weeks ago in
december 21st
a person was arrested who was on their
way from sacramento to washington dc
at a speed stop in iowa
and they asked the police asked him
where he was going
and he was going to washington dc
to kill dr fauci and they found in his
car
an ar-15 and multiple magazines of
ammunition
because he thinks that maybe i'm killing
people so i ask myself
why would senator want to do this
so go to
rand paul website
and you see
fire dr fauci with a little box that
says contribute here you can do five
dollars ten dollars twenty dollars a
hundred dollars so you are making a
catastrophic epidemic for your political
gain so the owner have politically
attacked your colleagues
so so rand paul interrupts without
addressing the substance politically
reprehensible
things like the representation okay he
won't defend it no don't argue it
turn around continue this hearing we
have a number of questions after another
one one more minute please dr kauchi i i
really appreciate your response but we
do have a number of of questions from
senators and we do have a second round
and i yeah
um that is essentially stochastic
terrorism i mean the story the story
that dr faushi tells there about guy
stopped with guns in the car
this happened with glenn beck years ago
right-wing propagandist glenn beck who
would just hammer on the tides
foundation he's obsessed with the tides
foundation the tides foundation and a
guy was actually stopped i believe by
california highway patrol with guns and
it was like what are you doing i'm going
to take care of the tides foundation
this is stochastic terrorism and not
only is rand paul doing it by it's just
attacking a doctor
he's also fundraising off of it fire dr
fauci
send me five dollars send me ten dollars
send me a hundred dollars or dr fauci
coming prepared with the receipts let's
look at one more clip here the last time
we had a committee of the time before he
was accusing me of being responsible for
the death
of five four to five million people
which is really irresponsible and i say
why is he doing that there are two
reasons why that's really bad yeah the
first is it distracts from what we're
all trying to do here today
is get our arms around
the epidemic and the pandemic that we're
dealing with the thing is that's not
actually what rand paul is there to do
dr fauci is naive in that for brand paul
this line of questioning isn't a
distraction it's the only thing he cares
about not something imaginary number two
what happens when he gets out
and accuses me of things that are
completely untrue
is that all of a sudden that kindles the
crazies out there and i have life that
threats upon my life
harassments of my family
and my children will have seen phone
calls because people are lying about me
now you know i guess you could say well
that's the way it goes and then he goes
into the segment that we looked at
earlier with regard to the person caught
in the car
this guy is disgusting rand paul and
these hearings are being used as a
platform to promote all sorts of
disinformation ted cruz did it later and
i'm going to talk about that but first i
want to deal with what i consider to be
the funniest moment of these hearings